amanda is with us in lansing michigan i
amanda how are you i am well how are you
David
better than I deserve what's up well my
husband and I are having some loud
accountability because we don't call it
a fight about selling a motorcycle so it
was my father's bike and I got it when
he passed away and I do not want to let
go of this and so we make around fifty
thousand years and we're we have thirty
six thousand ish in debt and our house
has about twenty six thousand west on it
we have a car for a 2000 a van for two
thousand my husband wants to sell the
bike to move us forward so I was
thinking you know we'll be out of debt
in what's around like worth um about two
thousand three hundred mm-hmm and is
there anything
owed on it no no it was inherited when
my dad passed away so how long ago did
pass away um for almost four years now
do you ride it yeah mm-hmm there's no
way I'd sell that you win no way yeah
you want
she's completely win cool you can't use
a lot of the bike it was a miscellaneous
motorcycle I'd sell it in about 20
seconds okay but there's only one of
this one in the world in the whole world
yes because I grew up on the back of it
because it was your dad's and you grew
up on the back of it and there's only
one you can't get it back it's like a
lady calling me and saying I have a
$2,300 diamond on my hand that is my
wedding ring in the executive in the
exact same scenario what else what about
is about where my heart set yeah well
it's the same thing it's it is very
nostalgic it's very much a part of your
life it's woven into the DNA of who you
are and there's only one you only have
one wedding ring well hypothetically but
this is
I mean you know you don't you don't sell
that now if there's extremes you might
have to I mean if you make $10,000 a
year and the wedding rings worth 200,000
and you're you know you're $100,000 in
debt well now those are extremes right
right and you'd have to stop and think
about it even then even if it was that
situation so um that that's the thing
and yeah I no way I'd sell that it does
not give you enough does not give you
enough traction and you can't get it
back right so Sully you win that easy
thanks for calling in hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]